our next guest has quite the resume
bozema St John has led marketing and
branding at some of the biggest
companies in the world including Pepsi
Apple music Uber and Netflix but her
latest projects personal her new Memoir
is the Urgent life my story of love loss
and survival in it she details tragedies
that shaped her life the loss of her
College boyfriend to Suicide a premature
baby who did not survive and her husband
Peter's death from cancer Bozeman St
John joins us now in studio thank you so
much for joining us
um what a book what an inspiration I
think you are to so many people men and
women but when you look at your life and
being able to be so Fearless what have
you learned through these experiences
and how do you pass that off to people
who might say but look at you you're so
accomplished how can I overcome and do
the things that you've been able to do
well it's I mean it's probably the
reason I wrote the book you know the
fact that um so many of us go through
traumas and loss of all kinds right we
just don't talk about it publicly you
know we don't acknowledge it
um maybe it makes us feel weak maybe it
makes us think that other people will
judge us for it you know that we can't
get over it or whatever that you know
phrase is right but for me it's um it's
it's about time you know for us to be
more open about the things that we're
going through because the truth of the
matter is that life is going to keep
coming coming you know and we can't be
fearful of it
um I think we'd be a better Society if
we better understood what we were each
going through and therefore be more
empathetic to each other and also then
live urgently you know be inspired
instead of be fearful yeah you you say
it's about time and time is of the
essence for some people other people
they think to themselves I have all the
time in the world but you use the word
urgent and
your husband's death it it created this
urgency in your life what do you mean by
that by living urgently yeah it's uh
that's a it's a actually a distinction
that I like to make like sometimes you
think urgency means let me live fast let
me live recklessly you know it's like
don't put any thought into what you're
doing just go go go that's not it at all
it was like what I learned
um through the months of my husband's
cancer and he was diagnosed and dead
within six months it wasn't a long
illness at all but what I learned was to
be intentional with the time you know
it's like you really have to decide what
is it that you want to do what's most
important to you and then do the thing
yeah like there's no there really is no
time to wait for it uh but you can't be
reckless in it either because we don't
want to waste the time of course we saw
that picture of your your husband your
late husband and your daughter what were
the conversations like with her because
at some point you have to explain to a
child yeah you know your father's yes
may not be here yes well she was four at
the time and uh I think these are Big
Concepts to understand when you're for
but I got some really great advice from
a friend who said use the right words
you know use the big words don't say oh
he's sick you don't say he has cancer
tell her he's going to die you know do
all of the things because you don't want
there to be any fear of sickness you
know that if someone has a cold or
anything else that somehow that that's
going to cause some additional trauma uh
or even understanding what death means
in terms of like you know is he around
is he not where did he go you know all
these questions it's hard for us to
tackle even as adults yeah what does
death mean also what is what does love
mean you guys uh life is complicated you
happen to be separated when he was
diagnosed uh and then later decided to
not go through with the divorce formally
did his loss or his diagnosis did that
moment change how you understand
relationships and love oh yes I mean so
much so
um I think sometimes we get caught up in
the small things you know that's one of
the biggest lessons during
um his last days was to forgive each
other
for all of the things you know sometimes
you get stuck in this cycle of pointing
out somebody's flaws you can't see
anything further and when you were faced
with the imminent loss you realize how
small those things are you know
um and to be honest with you I I
reconciled with him not not because he
just because he asked me to I did it for
myself too yeah before you go I have to
find out if this is true you were at the
concert in Dubai that Beyonce did you
know what I mean I don't want to jump
subjects but yes yes we're living like
the whole world was watching from the
outside in are you telling me you were
there and invited by Beyonce's team yes
that's correct I I was there and invited
I did not sneak on okay oh wow yes but
you got to live life how was it oh it
was fantastic this is it's about living
yeah in the moment
urgently yes so I went and had a good
time I had a good time a good time
wow you're gonna go to uh her upcoming
uh tour oh absolutely absolutely oh
there's you can get his tickets is that
the follow-up question um no but um I
will be in the background
you know people
yeah all right all right yeah St John
thank you so much we appreciate you the
Urgent life goes on sale tomorrow